Culture
of the cannon.
Okay.
If people you know,
asserted that the Canon was the product of bias and again,
have a,
you know,
of a,
of a provincial elite as in and so on,
but in point of fact as a student of history of the arts,
okay.
I can,
sure,
sure.
People the cannon.
Okay.
The overwhelmingly so is is the result of what artists have determined,
okay.
We,
we,
we did we say a work is important.
It's canonical because artists following it.
Okay.
We're influenced by it and we have this like beautiful cascading tradition of
influence.
All right.
So that,
that's another part of the Philistinism.
Okay.
I've current education to,
to,
you know,
to believe that there are these external reasons for why a work last,
why a work,
you know,
I'm a written 500 years ago or a thousand years ago,
has it
global relevance as if it's some sort of political conspiracy based on power as
if anybody could even manage that no matter how nefarious they weren't.
Right.
But also,
you know,
we,
in the 60s you ain't had the,
had the idea.
Okay.
Then there was a,
uh,
human human sensibility that transcendent individual nations and so on.
All right.
And that,
and that there was this like rubric,
cosmic consciousness and this son,
this a sense of the universe as a whole.
And to see the human being in relationship to great eternal principles of,
you know,
of life and death,
mortality and so on.
Whereas,
you know,
Marxism is blind.
Marxism is very narrow.
All it sees is a society.
Okay?
It says nothing be on society.
It doesn't seem nature.
Okay.
I mean,
it's absolutely mad.
Okay,
how are you going to have a system being taught,
okay?
And universities,
right?
Which,
which,
which thinks at this tiny thing of society.
Okay.
Compared to the enormity and beauty of nature,
it should take all of,
you know,
all of our,
absorb all of our energy and attention.
So,
I mean,
I just think that there's like a parochialism and provincialism uh,
you know,
it and now all kinds of,
um,
you know,
systematized,
elite TISM in our current education.
It's got to be rooted out and we,
I want to return to basics.
Great.
Simplicities and all these faculty members teaching their little tiny courses
that have to,
has to do with our own specialty.
That's got to stop.
What can people,
people can pursue whatever they want in their private research.
A scholars.
Okay.
Certainly that's necessary,
but they must teach in the core curriculum and,
and people must decide what is crucial for an educated person to know.
I do want a multicultural.
I do want to global curriculum like I want,
I want all the cultures taught.
Okay.
Right.
This is not the answer.
Martin Marxism,
this neo Marxism in the university's okay.
Is simply,
it's lazy.
It's a lazy way to assert multiculturalism without actually doing the research
and the study of other cultures.
Okay.
All right.
We agreed on everything.
I knew this.
I knew that.
All right,
great.